Before we can write any code, we need to figure out what the expected values
are. This green rectangle is what our rectangle grows to. This point should be
at 45 minus 20 and 90 minus 20. So our expected value of x, would be 25. And
your expected value of y would be 70. The width would be 60 plus 20 on one
side, and 20 on the other side, so 100. And the height would be 90 plus 20 at
the top and 20 at the bottom, so 130. So in the test program, I would create my
new rectangle and I would print out my expected value for x. And remember, this
is just a comment. And expected value for y, expected value for width, and the
expected value for height. I want to compare these to the actual values.
box.getX, gets me the, actual value, of X for box. Box.getY gets the actual
value for Y for the box. And I do the same thing for width and heighth. Now I
can run my test program. I had a couple of syntax errors, so I just fixed those
up, and now I can actually run it. And I printed, 45, 25, 90, 70, 60, 100, 90,
and 130. Looks like the actual values don't match my expectations. What went
wrong? It looks like I created the rectangle and then printed out the actual
and expected values without actually calling grove. And now if I run it again,
I get the actual is 70, expected is 70, 100, 100, 130, 130, and 25, 25. That's
much better. Based on these test results, I'd say the grow method works about,
the way it says it will.